[SPEAKER_00]: Third Wealsun, Jude's conversation with Lord Jameis continued.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, what might also help me in any future work with you, and I don't know if you can give me a kill on sight list.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it would have been nice to know if you...
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I was acting on my own accord, thinking that we needed to bring Fairwind here, but if there's ever anybody... At this point, Fairwind is not a kill on site, Jude.
[SPEAKER_00]: I do not want him assassinated.
[SPEAKER_00]: The fact that he is not fully aware of the political situation...
[SPEAKER_00]: Means that in the future it's possible he could realize that his loyalty lives with the Sea Principality and the Prince of Toli is actually the one that is more dangerous than Gion.
[SPEAKER_00]: And that this game he's playing weakens himself.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think any of the princes will survive what the Tolis want to bring.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is what I agree.
[SPEAKER_01]: How is Monmurg set?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, just on the embargo, food, are we suffering mass desertions?
[SPEAKER_01]: Are we able to keep...
[SPEAKER_01]: The situation is dire.
[SPEAKER_00]: Our stores are going down greatly.
[SPEAKER_00]: We do get some food from smugglers that go to Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's where the majority of the merchant ships are.
[SPEAKER_00]: You saw this yourself.
[SPEAKER_00]: You brought me the information.
[SPEAKER_00]: My spies have verified what you've said.
[SPEAKER_00]: I find it interesting that Red Shore approached you and you had discussions with him and I might have more to say on that in the future.
[SPEAKER_00]: There may be an opening there.
[SPEAKER_00]: I may send you as an envoy to talk to him in the future.
[SPEAKER_00]: Again, I believe that not only is Fairwind and Gion being played by the Toli, I have a feeling that the Sea Principalities and Keoland itself are being played by other nefarious forces as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is dangerous.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know if you know much of what is happening in Keoland at this point, but it seems like a civil war is imminent in that country.
[SPEAKER_00]: Between?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, the Dukes.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Duke of Gratzel.
[SPEAKER_00]: Who for all intents and purposes should have been crowned king some decade, 12 years ago, was denied that and has been trying to become king ever since.
[SPEAKER_00]: The king that was appointed 12 years ago, this unknown Iridium from the back province called Greyhill, Kimbertus Scotty, recently died.
[SPEAKER_00]: And so there is no king sitting upon the lion throne at this point.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there any suspicion that he was assassinated?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, the royal alchemist died a month before the king died.
[SPEAKER_00]: And so it is very suspicious what is happening.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is Gratzel, the Duke of Gratzel, the greater problem for the Sea Princess or for Lord Gion?
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, I'm just going to suggest that Lord Gion is the only one that I'm talking about when I say the Sea Princess.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because we're on the verge of civil war with the Toli and depending on where Farewell is.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think it's already started to be honest with you.
[SPEAKER_01]: When you talk to Lord Jeon, Prince Jeon, do let them know that Fairwind, I had made a comment about taking the island back from the hobgoblins as a necessity for Monmurg, and he responded that he thought that Monmurg would fall without the helm.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he knows at least the gravity.
[SPEAKER_00]: He understands exactly the gravity of the situation.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I think that, again, he's playing a very dangerous game.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have no idea.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, to be honest with you, he's always been jealous of the prosperity of Monmurg, the money and such.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I think he's been outspoken in that he believes the negotiations with regards to slavery with Toli and Berkhoff are unnecessary.
[SPEAKER_00]: He thinks it's idealistic to try and stop something that predates our country in truth.
[SPEAKER_00]: But these are minor.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why he has gone to such lengths at this point is beyond me.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's very dangerous.
[SPEAKER_00]: And that is something I would like you to try and ascertain, if you could.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are several things I want you to try and figure out, that being one of them.
[SPEAKER_00]: The second one is this.
[SPEAKER_00]: The salting ships did salt the seas before the helm was able to do what it did.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why did that not take effect?
[SPEAKER_00]: Was some magic cast to cause the substance to not do what it was supposed to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Could it be that Lord Fairwin was replacing the barrels as he took them?
[SPEAKER_00]: I need to know that.
[SPEAKER_00]: If it is that he basically changed the barrels and put a substitute in there that was not effective, that would be even more treasonous.
[SPEAKER_00]: More evidence of what he'd been doing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or is it the substances becoming less effective?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or the sahuagin learning to overcome it?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or is it that there is some counter-agent that can overcome this?
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to know that and I think that you should be investigating that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is the tower equipped with anything or is it just housing?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll have whatever you want brought there.
[SPEAKER_00]: And of course you can take books to and from for your own research.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now there is another matter and to be honest with you I am
[SPEAKER_00]: Hesitant to ask this, but Prince Gian has insisted on it.
[SPEAKER_00]: He believes that Paul Rivera will make an excellent wizard and he wants you to tutor him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is Paul interested?
[SPEAKER_00]: Gian is going to push him in that direction.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I can see what he's, if he's got a natural talent for it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Did he make that homunculi?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
Okay.
Hey.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm gonna go to the store.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think Roman's gonna go with me so he can catch me up on his life.
[SPEAKER_00]: Get some beer?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Want me to get you a beer?
[SPEAKER_00]: Beer.
[SPEAKER_00]: Twelve pack.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nothing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Whatever, IP, whatever you guys like.
[SPEAKER_01]: You like the romadella, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I like what you guys like, though.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I'm not gonna drink more than one or two, so...
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hey, um... Then we won't get Napoleon Zello.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, get whatever you guys like.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know if you want me to show like a resume to that superintendent lady, but I'd be willing to.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I mean, it's not anything in a hurry because like if you guys maybe or maybe not coming back in March or April or even if it's for next year, just sometime in the next four, five, six months.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because what I can do is I can kind of like put it in front of the person.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let her see.